Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonsoir !
Je suis issu de l’accouplement
d’une psychiatre et d’un joueur de PMU.
(Rires)
C’est un peu réducteur
pour mes chers géniteurs,
mais je trouve que ça me ressemble bien.
J’ai passé de nombreuses heures
de mon enfance dans les PMU
et j’ai toujours été fasciné par tous
les parieurs gagnants que je croisais.
À en croire ces joueurs invétérés,
ils n’arrêtaient pas de gagner,
tout le temps.
Bon, bizarrement, je ne voyais pas
à l’extérieur des PMU
des grosses voitures de luxe garées.
Bref.
Un jour, à dix ans,
je choisis deux chevaux,
ils finissent premier et deuxième.
Un couplé gagnant.
Je gagne plus de 500 francs.
À moi les montagnes de Playmobil,
(Rires)
les étiquettes Panini par tonnes
et les glaces à l’italienne.
Hooked !
Accroché.
« Hooked », c’est le terme anglais pour
parler des personnes qui sont addicts.
J’ai continué à parier
avec mon père comme ça,
sans dommages spécifiques,
jusqu’à mes 22 ans.
J’avais aussi les jeux vidéo
qui permettaient de nourrir ces besoins.
Et puis, en 2004,
je reçois mon premier salaire.
Quelques mois plus tard,
je vois une pub passer sur Internet
pour les paris sportifs.
« 100 % bonus », « 200 euros offerts »,
« 100 pounds Free bet ».
J’adore « Free bet »
parce que ça veut dire « paris gratuits »,
mais dans le mot « free »,
il y a aussi une notion de liberté.
Je trouve ça un peu vicieux,
isn’t it ?
(Rires)
Vous avez peut-être aussi vu :
« Gros gains, gros respect ! »
(Rires)
Ouais !
Ce n’est pas forcément
une publicité mensongère.
Disons qu’il manque une autre partie :
« Grosses pertes, grosse honte ».
L’enfer du décor des paris sportifs,
messieurs dames.
Selon l’Observatoire du jeu,
rien qu’en France, entre 2014 et 2019,
les joueurs problématiques ont doublé.
En 2019, on a plus d’un million de joueurs
dits « addicts modérés »
et plus de 340 000 joueurs excessifs.
Selon une étude internationale,
plus de 20% des joueurs excessifs
tenteront de se suicider.
Pour ma part, je faisais partie
plutôt des addicts modérés.
Je pariais des sommes raisonnables,
mais disons que j’y passais un temps fou.
Je pariais parfois la nuit,
souvent le matin, le midi, le soir,
le week-end, les jours fériés,
en vacances,
en dîner entre amis et en famille.
Vous savez les moments où on est censé
être chaleureux et détendu.
Moi, j’étais accroché à mon téléphone.
Pas toujours ...
fier, tout simplement.
95% des parieurs sont perdants.
Pour revenir à mon histoire :
entre temps, j’étais devenu banquier
dans la gestion des risques.
(Rires)
Je vous avais dit que j'étais raisonnable,
En 2017, je vais travailler
à Londres, à la City,
et là-bas, c’est le royaume
des bookmakers et des paris.
Il y a des boutiques de paris
à chaque coin de rue.
Je me dis que s’il y en a à chaque coin
de rue, ça ne va pas être si grave.
Après, quand je voyais
le style des habitués,
je me disais quand même : « Bon... »
Mais bon, moi, je suis fort,
il n’y avait pas de raison.
Toujours est-il qu’en 2010,
je repars à Paris
avec une addiction bien musclée
et la ferme intention de travailler
à la Française des Jeux
dans les paris sportifs.
Mon rêve.
En juin 2010, mon rêve se réalise.
Je suis embauché en CDI à la Française
des Jeux en trader paris sportifs.
L’extase !
Comme un drogué qui devient dealer.
(Rires)
Un vrai poison dans l'eau.
Fin 2010,
j’ai la vie qui m’envoie deux messages.
Je perds successivement en six mois
mon meilleur ami - il avait 29 ans -
et mon père, 58 ans.
Autant pour mon ami j’ai eu
des sentiments plutôt normaux -
choc, déni, colère,
un fort sentiment d’injustice -
pour mon père, j’ai eu toutes ces
émotions en une seule journée.
Ça a été remplacé très vite
par un sentiment étrange.
Je me suis rendu compte
que 29 fois deux égalent 58,
que mon père avait vécu
deux fois plus que mon ami,
et qu’en fait, il avait eu de la chance.
Je me suis dit
que mon pote avait vécu deux fois plus que
quelqu’un de mort à 14 ans et demi, etc.
Je me suis dit : « Et si finalement,
on avait la chance d’être en vie ? »
Ce sentiment étrange, c'est la gratitude.
Devant cette trouvaille, je me suis
dit : « Tiens, je vais marquer le coup
et faire mon premier sketch
d’humour noir dans une église
pour l’oraison funèbre de mon père. »
(Rires)
Quitte à faire les choses,
autant bien les faire.
Et ce jour-là, j’ai lâché beaucoup
de valises remplies de peur
et j’ai libéré d’autres choses.
J’aime bien dire que
j’ai craqué mon SLEEP.
S.L.E.E.P.
Une sorte d’éveil spirituel
rempli d’humour inconditionnel.
A partir de là,
j’ai commencé à faire du théâtre.
Quelques années plus tard,
je plaque ma vie normale
pour devenir comédien humoriste.
J’ai fait un premier one man show qui
s’appelait « L’effet mère doit perdurer ».
(Rires)
J’étais aussi accro
aux jeux de mots à l’époque.
Oui, on peut très bien cumuler
les addictions.
Ça marche très bien.
En 2015, je deviens formateur,
en 2018, coach de vie comme tout le monde.
(Rires)
Vous en connaissez plein, hein ?
Oui, d’accord.
En 2020, l’an dernier, je suis certifié
« Process Communication Model ».
C’est grâce à ce modèle
que j’ai totalement arrêté de parier.
Alors, messieurs dames,
comment parier sur la vie
et faire partie des 5% de gagnants ?
Ben oui, le bonheur :
100% des gagnants ont tenté leur chance.
En un, la gratitude.
Selon le Dr Ali Binazir de Harvard,
nous aurions une chance sur 700 trillions
de naître - 700 milliards de milliards.
Pour vous donner un ordre d’idée, ça fait
5 000 milliards de fois plus de chances
de gagner à l’Euromillions que de naître.
La vie est notre jackpot, les amis.
La mort est également
très riche d’enseignements.
Je suis convaincu que le fait
d’être dans le déni de la mort
ou de ne pas vouloir
voir certaines choses,
de se dire que c’est injuste, grave ou que
ça va arriver quand on sera très vieux,
je pense qu’on ne s’autorise pas
à être heureux maintenant.
Je suis convaincu que
la conscience de la mort,
c’est la clé pour ne plus
avoir peur de la vie.
Moi, ça fait 10 ans que
je parle beaucoup de la mort
et ça fait 10 ans
que je suis très heureux.
Ce n'est pas une coïncidence.
Alors un conseil, regardez
la mort droit dans les yeux,
approchez-vous, écoutez, et elle va
vous murmurer votre mission de vie.
Ensuite, la connaissance de soi.
Je vous disais
qu’avec le Process Communication Model,
j’ai appris plein de choses sur moi,
et notamment que nous avions
tous des besoins psychologiques,
à la fois communs
et également spécifiques.
J’ai appris avec ce modèle
que j’avais des besoins d’excitation
et de contact ludique
bien plus forts que la moyenne.
(Rires)
Vous aviez remarqué ?
Pendant toutes ces années, je les
nourrissais avec un mauvais comportement.
Le but, c’est juste de réajuster.
Donc depuis, j’ai réajusté.
Je fais des formations, des conférences,
ce genre de choses.
Et j’ai nourri mon besoin
de challenge avec l’entrepreneuriat,
avec des défis sportifs,
avec la créativité aussi.
Par exemple, j’adore chanter.
Je ne chanterai pas
malheureusement ce soir -
ou pas, ça dépend, bref !
Le principe :
nourrir ses besoins psychologiques
avec des comportements positifs.
C'est aussi simple que ça.
Enfin, la connexion aux autres.
Pour moi, c’étaient les paris sportifs.
Pour des personnes qui auraient
des besoins de solitude
et d’introspection très forts,
elles pourraient se tourner vers
des drogues qui isolent encore plus.
Pour d’autres personnes qui auraient
du mal à gérer leurs émotions,
elles pourraient
les noyer dans de l’alcool.
D'autres personnes mangeront
leurs émotions.
Certains fumeront pour être plus libres.
Et certaines personnes
accros au perfectionnisme
iront jusqu’au burn-out pour se prouver
qu’elles maîtrisent tout à la perfection.
Je pense qu’on a tous en nous
quelque chose d’addiction.
Ah, le Bonus 100% gratuit, hein ?
Loto dérision.
(Rires)
L.O.T.O.
Qu’est-ce que c’est que ce truc-là ?
C’est le jeu de l’humour de soi
et de l’amour de soi,
et par effet miroir,
l’amour des autres et l’amour de la vie.
Ça, c'est la plus belle des addictions.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)